That shows really weird.
Who wants to watch a cartoon about people crying?
I do.
This is the first in a series of videos that we'll be exploring what Steven
Universe has to say about men,
boys and masculinity.
Steven Universe is an animated show on cartoon network created by Rebecca Sugar.
It focuses on the adventures with the crystal gems,
Garnet,
Pearl,
Amethyst,
and of course Steven.
This series is exceptional for a whole bunch of reasons,
not least of which is because it's filled with powerful,
confident women who are central to the show and its plot.
Now,
if you haven't seen the show yet,
just pause this video right here and go and do that because it is good.
I mean really seriously good,
and currently there are something like 85 episodes and there about 10 minutes
long each,
which means that if you start right now,
you can watch them all in like 15 hours.
So once you've gone and done that does come back and pause the video and keep
watching.
All right?
All right.
Those of you who do follow the series probably already know that Steven Universe
has received a huge amount of praise for its diversity,
for it's feminist themes and for its positive depictions of queer relationship.
It really is remarkable for an adventure show to do any of this,
let alone one that's made for a younger audience.
But today I want to talk about something else that makes the show really
extraordinary,
something that gets maybe a little less attention and that is the way that it
represents masculinity.
Now,
it may not seem like it at first glance,
but there is a ton of depth to this show.
So I want to break this discussion down into a few different parts,
but I want to start off by talking about emotional expression and highlight the
ways in which crying,
affection and fear are framed on the series.
Well,
I guess I'm just too tough to cry.
Just today you were crying about snakes.
They don't have any arms.
You've probably heard the old adage,
boys don't cry,
but on Steven Universe,
everyone cries.
Men and boys absolutely cry and their tiers are not portrayed as a sign of
weakness.
You saved me instead crying as depicted as a perfectly normal and healthy thing
for everyone to do.
It certainly is Steven.
Incidentally,
when I say that crying is healthy,
I mean that quite literally in both the physiological and the psychological
sense because tears are one of the best ways to relieve stress.
I should also mention that on Steven Universe,
tears are not limited to expressions of sadness.
Instead crying is used to express all of different emotions.
There are tears or pride,
tears of loss,
tears of self pity,
tears of anger,
tears of joy,
tears of suffering,
tears of fear,
tears of love,
tears of concern,
tears of bravery,
tiers of admiration,
tears of embarrassment,
tears of desperation,
tears of morning tears of betrayal,
tears of relief,
tears of confusion.
It's tears of regret,
tiers of determination and many,
many more because tears are so common and so varied crying,
it's just accepted as a normal response to all kinds of situations and that
normalization then opens up space on the show for it to occasionally poke fun.
At a character per behaving in a foolish or melodramatic way without poking fun
at the act of crying itself.
The series also has a fantastic sense of humor about all this crying as
evidenced by Steven's favorite cartoon show.
Stay tuned for another episode of crime.
Breakfast.
Friends,
I must be getting old.
She's the light cartoons.
Open expression of vulnerability is extremely gendered in Western media culture
being emotional,
especially crying is seen as stereotypically feminine as girl stuff.
We're all familiar with this stereotype that women are over emotional or
irrational or too sensitive.
Now,
of course that stereotype is complete nonsense.
Everyone has these emotions and everyone has these feelings.
In fact,
research has shown that male infants actually display more emotional expression
than female infants do,
but our society teaches boys at a very early age that it is not okay for them to
display their vulnerable sides.
We're taught that young man should bottle up most of their feelings.
The anger or aggression may sometimes be permissible for some men in certain
situations,
but that vulnerability is strictly off limits because it's been culturally
associated with weakness.
But on Steven Universe,
vulnerability is not equated with weakness.
Instead,
it simply equated with being a human being.
Dad,
please,
I have to go back.
I have to.
They don't have my shield.
You do.
You understand?
Yeah.
Okay.
Just be careful.
Oh,
I'm going to run fresh out of family.
Stay with everyone and keep them safe.
We see men and boys openly sharing their emotions and talking about their
feelings with their friends and their family.
No one is told to toughen up and no one has made to feel that expressing their
feelings is something to be ashamed of.
What are you smiling about?
You loved her.
Both physical and verbal expressions of affection,
of love and of support are freely given in Stephen's world.
On Steven Universe.
There are lots and lots of hugs,
so,
so very many hugs.
I love you honey.
Welcome.
Well done.
Mock it up.
We gotta go find a slicker.
No,
it's up time
and just like crying.
Physical signs of affection hold a vast array of different emotional meanings.
There are hugs of constellations.
It's okay.
We're here.
Hugs,
up,
protection,
hugs.
If forgiveness,
hugs of support.
I am so proud of you.
Yeah,
you to and I knew you could do it
and so many more.
It's also common for characters to express their love and their support for each
other very directly by simply telling them that that's how they feel.
Oh,
Steven,
there's one more thing I have to mention.
What is it?
I love you.
Bye.
I love you paradox.
Why are you getting so worked up?
You care them using beans.
This emotional expression is all out there in the open,
so we as the audience don't need to read between the lines on Steven Universe.
Characters don't need to mask their affection for each other behind cynicism or
teasing or self deprecating humor as tends to happen on some other animated
shows.
It's a very brave thing to show love and affection for others and to do it whole
heartedly like Steven does well.
I think you're pretty great.
Tender and loving behavior is never framed as embarrassing or unmanly and his
world and it's not reserved only for romance either.
This is especially remarkable when it comes to depictions of men's relationships
with each other.
We see affection being actively encouraged,
even between straight men,
particularly between Steven and yes
father,
but also between Steven and his friends,
including be
cool.
Okay,
that's nuts.
Now a quick note here,
emotional expression is not the same thing as just having feelings.
Men,
even fictional men are not robots.
Well,
I mean they're mostly not.
Almost all male characters in media are meant to have feelings.
At least at some point,
these feelings are communicated to the audience through a variety of filmmaking
techniques.
But most of the time,
men don't openly share those feelings.
Instead,
male characters choose to keep it to themselves except under a very narrow set
of traumatic circumstances.
We're showing feelings is momentarily acceptable,
like when a loved one dies,
for example.
So when we're talking about emotional expression,
we're not just talking about men having feelings,
we're talking about male characters that openly share and communicate those
feelings to others onscreen.
Okay,
so we've seen how crying and affection are not framed as weak or shameful,
but what about fear?
How has being afraid portrayed on the show?
The first thing to note is that on Steven Universe,
being scared is not framed as something negative.
Being afraid is instead portrayed as normal and as healthy.
Now remember,
Steven,
if you run into any trouble out there,
you can always bail.
There's never any shame in baling fatherly advice.
Understood.
Thank you dad.
This approach differs from many other coming of age stories in which courage is
often conflated with fearlessness.
In those narratives,
young men must learn to bury their fear of deep down because showing that you're
afraid is widely seen as an act of cowardice.
This media message,
that fear is somehow shameful or unmanly then encourages young men to go out and
take dangerous,
unnecessary risks in a misguided quest to look like tough guys who have no fear.
It's true that unchecked fear can turn into paranoia and then drive people to
lash out and harm others and that's obviously not good.
But here's the thing about fear.
Fear is a natural human emotion.
It's a natural reaction to danger.
It's a biological response with a purpose and it's purpose is to keep us safe
and healthy.
That's fierce job
space
and as such,
it's an important emotional part of life.
Fear can help us assess when a situation may be too risky or too dangerous.
[inaudible]
it's fear that tells us,
hey,
maybe it's not a good idea to go run around with scissors or play football and
traffic on the highway.
So only when Steven,
let's his fear control and consume him,
does it become a problem?
Tell me what's going to happen with my lunch too.
I choke on a pickle.
You don't choke on a Google.
That means something else happens with the big goal,
but as long as fear is not consistent or completely debilitating,
it can be a very healthy thing.
Time and again,
the show communicates that listening to your fears
kind of show it to
important step in building a good plan of action moving forward.
Why are you
all,
we're not going to make it
in Stephen's world,
acknowledging and being sensitive to your own fears.
He's a true demonstration of bravery,
Steven.
The truth
is with skin,
we've been scared before,
right?
None of us know what's going to happen,
but that's okay.
We can figure things out together.
As I mentioned earlier,
men and boys in our culture are expected to learn to bottle up their emotions.
Men may be allowed to have feelings,
but ultimately they're encouraged to keep those feelings buried deep inside.
Most of the time,
the series addresses this gendered convention directly in the episode.
Full disclosure,
Stephen is feeling overwhelmed and scared for the safety of his loved ones and
seeing this,
his friend Ronaldo gives him some terrible,
terrible advice.
Yes,
Steven.
That's just what people like us do suffer quietly shouldering the knowledge.
No one else can bear.
This is no easy path we've chosen here.
There are sacrifices.
Look at them all down there,
Steven.
It's our duty to let those simple people live out their simple lives without
ever knowing the burden of being friends with us.
That idea that men should shoulder difficult burdens all by themselves to
protect those who are close to them is something deeply ingrained in our culture
and it's evidence of a very unhealthy form of masculinity and one that makes
interpersonal connections with others really difficult when men feel they must
go it alone emotionally.
It forces them to deceive their loved ones and try to face all of life's
challenges without any support.
But Steven Universe is not a show about going it alone.
In fact,
this is a show about the opposite.
It's time I got serious.
Steven,
why is your communication device playing that song?
It's Connie trying to call me,
but I can't face her anymore so you're just going to ignore her forever.
It's the responsible thing to do.
It's going to be hard cause she's coming up the steps right now.
Although Stephen initially believes he must isolate himself to protect those
around him.
The show has a very different lesson in store.
I don't want to be friends anymore.
In classic,
one of the Tough Guy Fashion Steven tells his friend Connie to leave him alone
to is heavy burden.
Steven,
I can't be with you anymore.
I have a destiny.
Say it to my face,
but she refuses to leave him alone.
She has persisted
and Steven ultimately decides to open up to her.
I still want to be friends.
Steven,
your eye,
what happened to
you?
I didn't want you to worry about it.
I've been worried sick all day.
What do you think I'm doing here?
I just wanted to protect you.
Stop.
Just tell me everything.
He cries and he tells her the truth about his feelings,
demonstrating that he has the courage to be openly vulnerable in front of her.
I can't stress enough how unusual this is for any piece of media.
This series is not content to simply hint at what the protagonist maybe feeling
deep down inside like so many other superhero stories.
Batman on Steven Universe,
male heroes don't brood or stew with unspoken emotion.
They dare to share their feelings openly with others.
In the end,
Steven's emotional.
Honesty is rewarded.
Connie is supportive of his feelings and affectionately reaffirms that she is
there for him.
No matter what
the least I could do is just listen.
I can't ask you to do that.
I want to,
Steven,
I want to be a part of your universe.
The lesson here is that men and boys don't need to protect their loved ones from
things that might scare them.
Men Don't have to weather the storm alone.
Instead,
we can work through life's struggles together with our friends,
our lovers,
and our families.
It's going to take a long time for us to collectively unlearn these harmful
notions about detached manhood,
but Steven's open and emotionally expressive version of masculinity.
That's an inspirational example for us.
All.
Next time we'll talk about Steven's powers and how those powers are connected to
empathy.
I hope this video made you even more excited about Steven Universe.
If you'd like to see more videos related to media and manhood,
hop on over to my patrion page and help fund the pop culture detective agency.
Yeah.
Hmm.